you know when you're walking down the
street and you see a dude and he's
muscular and you think to yourself that
guy looks pretty good he's nice and
jacked he takes care of himself a stupid
question is wondering how he got that
way cuz everybody kind of knows you kind
of know that he probably goes to the gym
in fact he definitely goes to the gym
that guy shows up to the gym regularly
and has probably been doing that for a
long time and he looks that way what
doesn't matter is how he got to the gym
what doesn't matter is his reasons for
going to the gym gy maybe he's super
angry at some ex you know he's like
Revenge lifting or maybe he has a very
healthy outlook on life he loves himself
so much as he tucks himself in at night
and he thinks about how lovely it is to
go to the gym and he just can't wait to
go there or maybe it takes him all day
to summon up the motivation to go to the
gym and he finally guilts himself out of
self-loathing to walk in the door but
ultimately none of that matters it
doesn't matter how much or how little
mental resistance was in the way for him
to go to the gym because all we see is
the result of him making a binary
decision to end up going to the gym more
often than not over a long period of
time almost everything in life is like
this more often than not life is exactly
as simple as we need it to be and it's
us that brings the complication into
life we completely over complicate
things we like to paint this very
emotional picture we like to have
strange incentive structures maybe some
guilt maybe some excitement motivation
we add some weird things to things that
probably don't need to be so weird if we
want certain outcomes in life it'll
almost certainly come down to either
doing or not doing things that we
already know need doing or not doing and
anytime this becomes clouded it's almost
always because we clouded it the things
aren't clouded so here's kind of a weird
example so I have two well well I have
three sisters but I have two sisters in
University and they're always writing
essays always writing papers and I
sometimes have to help them out with it
sister number one generally has very
little roadblocks in the way of just
writing a paper you know 99% of papers
you have to write at school aren't
actually papers they're kind of just
like Reflections and sort of polished
train of thought it's like what do you
think about this article sister number
one just writes it it's probably pretty
good and she gets decent grades sister
number two will procras
and really try to think about the best
possible way to write this and whether
it's good enough or maybe do I sound
stupid or maybe it sounds like I haven't
even done the readings and it's so
emotionally and psychologically taxing
for her to do these Reflections it's
almost hilarious to watch but
unsurprisingly she always ends up doing
it they both always end up doing it and
the funny thing is they get pretty
similar grades right it's kind of a wash
and that really got me thinking it's
like sister number two just do it you're
not going to think your way into
becoming all of a sudden like a 600%
better writer here's another example if
you are a single male and you lie awake
at night wondering why you're not
married with Children yet and you're
also somebody who doesn't ask girls out
ever you don't go on dates you don't do
any of that stuff then you might as well
not bother feeling bad about yourself
because you already know what the
solution to your problem is if you want
to find a wife you probably have to ask
a girl out so the next girl that you
come across that you want to ask out
just know that you can either ask her
out or not ask her out and if you choose
not to her life will go on and your life
will go on and everything will probably
work out okay but you're not going to be
married so if you want that outcome you
have to behave a certain way you have to
ask girls out if you want to eventually
get married if you just almost look at
things like a robot it might help you we
might need a little bit more robot
energy in our lives where we kind of
just take the over complication of the
human psyche out of it and just perform
optimally when it comes to tasks and
just getting things done you don't need
emotion right you can bring emotion into
things that actually require it art
relationships wait but I just said you
got to not think about asking a girl out
so maybe not relationships maybe asking
her out is like not a big deal and you
should just do it and then on the date
bring your personality with you
hopefully you understand the point I'm
trying to make and I'm not just sounding
like a complete idiot in front of you
and one of the best ways to not sound
like a complete idiot all the time is to
educate yourself more often by listening
to Quality audio books using today's
video sponsor audible so the audiobook
that I've been listening to recently is
outlive by Peter AA outlive is all about
longevity and health and it really gets
you thinking there are things that you
can do in your life objectively that
will maximize your lifespan and your
health span which are two different
things anyways I'm not quite done the
audiobook yet but I'm really enjoying it
so far are so I highly recommend it and
for those of you who don't know audible
is the leading provider of audio
entertainment and audiobooks allinone
place every single month they send you
one credit which you can spend on any
audiobook of your choice regardless of
cost and you get to keep that audio book
forever audible members also get instant
access to a rapidly expanding catalog of
audible Originals podcasts and exclusive
series also make sure that you check out
my personal curated listening list using
my link below and also check out
audible's best of 2023 list because
there's some really cool titles on there
as well and if you use my link in the
description below or text better ideas
to 500500 you'll get a 30-day free trial
once again visit my link below or text
better ideas to 500500 to get a 30-day
free trial and thanks again to Audible
for sponsoring this video okay so how do
we apply all of this well I think the
bottom line is we all have to just slow
ourselves down
we have to take a deep breath and just
think about the few most important
things that we have to do think about
them as objectively as possible call
them by name maybe it's something like
do my taxes or submit my firearms
application license to the RCMP you know
for instance clean my toilet whatever
those things are just try to look at
them as if they are text and then pick
one and do it unthinkingly
right just perform the action and on
your own time when you're soaking in the
bathtub or pampering yourself or
watching succession you can think to
yourself what's my life all about you
know where do I want to be in life what
what are my hopes and dreams you can
think about bigger pictures stuff but at
the end of the day to get there you just
have to do certain unemotional things
that are either done or not
done so you just kind of have to do them
right not a big deal just do them